it looks like a relic of an industrial
past
a balto in inner mongolia north china is
crucial to our green future
it is the global capital for rare earth
elements metals that are crucial for all
sorts of technology especially renewable
energy and the authorities are paying
close attention to us
so we've only just got to baoter we have
quite the escort already four cars full
of men following us this is a sensitive
topic wind turbines and solar panels are
impossible without rare earths but this
clean technology
has a dirty secret
this is the byproduct of rare earth
processing a vast toxic and radioactive
tailings pond stretching for miles
open to the air but even worse seeping
into the ground below
it has poisoned the water for the
villagers who live nearby
these farmers had just finished watering
their fields
he tells us about a nearby village where
the problem was even worse
foreign
as we said goodbye an unidentified man
took the farmers aside to question them
this kept happening
this woman lives nearby the polluted
tailings pond
she starts explaining what happened but
doesn't get the chance
their local officials and they ordered
us to leave
for three days we're followed by up to
eight cars at the same time
they won't say who they are or why
they're following us they won't even
admit they're following us when i asked
them
they watch every step we take
if you want to understand how much the
authorities don't want you to see sites
like that when we put this drone up
those people over there got a gps
spoofer they've been following us all
day a gps spoofer which basically sent
our drone haywire we couldn't control it
it landed a long way away from where we
were
this is a sensitive topic for chinese
officials who are aware of the damage
caused by the pollution
we asked the local government and the
state-owned company that operates the
tailing ponds for their response but
received no reply
professor julie klinger has spent years
researching china's rare earth metal
industry the policy priority up to um
the end of the first decade of the 21st
century was really around
production first you know develop first
and clean up later
um about 12 years ago the policy
priority shifted now you could say that
we're kind of in the cleanup phase
but this is not just a problem of the
past the threat of severe pollution to
an even wider area remains it's also
been leaching for the past several
decades
toward the yellow river
um
this battalion's dam has been steadily
draining over time
now where the waste material is going
that i don't know
this is the yellow river it's known as
china's mother river and its basin is
home to 160 million people
there is great urgency in our transition
to renewable energy
but this new industrial revolution risks
repeating the mistakes of the old one
tom cheshire sky news battle